hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom with sal
live stream we have a very exciting show
today we have i would say two
mega figures in the world of education
we have carol dweck a professor at
stanford
you all might know her for her really
pioneering work around growth mindset
really coined the term author of mind
shift we also have vicki colbert who's
the executive director of the nueva
escuela or escuela nueva foundation
fandession escuela nueva which is a
really incredible a series of schools
and a new learning model through latin
america that has made huge impact on the
world both of them are actually the
first i believe the first two winners of
the
the don prize
in education uh globally so we have two
titans of education so start thinking of
your questions for either carol or vicky
but before we do that i will give some
of my standard announcements first of
all a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit we can only do what we do
because of donations from folks like
yourself so if you can go to khan
academy.org donate and whatever you're
capable of it could make a huge
difference if you're in a position to do
so
also want to give a shout out to several
organizations that stepped up especially
during the pandemic many of y'all know
that our traffic grew by a factor of
three during the pandemic
and our costs went up and we tried to
accelerate a whole series of programs
and so we wouldn't have been able to do
that without the support of the folks on
the screen bank of america att
google.org novartis fastly general
motors and many other supporters large
and small uh who allow khan academy to
build what we do and create the content
that we do
last but not least i want to remind
folks that there is a version of this
live stream that you can get wherever
you get your podcast homeroom with sal
the podcast so with that i am very
excited to introduce both carol and
vicky carol vicki welcome
thank you
great to be here with you
so i wish i could have two hours with
each of you so but i think we're gonna
there's a lot for us to cover
uh but maybe maybe i'll start with you
carol i think a lot of folks who've been
in education know about growth mindset
but if you could tell me for anyone who
who's been under a rock for the last
several decades
what what is a growth mindset and why in
your mind has been this why has this
work
been
why why is it caught the the zeitgeist
so to speak of education and and maybe a
little bit of what are the
misconceptions around it
um thanks sal a growth mindset is the
belief
that your fundamental abilities are not
fixed but can be developed
it's in contrast to a fixed mindset
where the belief is
your abilities are
genetically based or in some way
fixed and you are what you are and you
have what you have and that's how you
stay
i think
the growth mindset caught on for several
reasons
first we've done decades of work
showing how when students believe
that their abilities can be developed
they have greater motivation to learn
they're
less afraid to take on challenges less
discouraged by mistakes they're
developing something they're not afraid
of it's being judged deficient
um
this was a new way of seeing students
seeing them
not as
people that you sort into the smart and
not smart but people
you can develop
help them realize their full potential i
think it's exciting for teachers to
believe that
every single child in front of them
has
unknown potential that you can unlock
now some of the misconceptions
um
it's not always
so intuitive how you communicate
a growth mindset to your students
so
some teachers thought just tell them to
work hard tell them you can learn
anything tell them everyone's smart
but what we have found over time
is that
growth mindset is a classroom culture
it's not something you say to kids or or
um
put a poster in front of the room it's
something that you bake into the culture
of the classroom
and have all kinds of practices that
support it
like
making sure every student knows you care
about their learning believe
they can learn to a high level making
sure
they know you think they can learn from
their mistakes the mistakes don't mean
they're
incompetent
um
letting kids
redo work to raise their grade and
demonstrate their understanding focusing
on the progress not
immediate performance so
now we're really focused on this idea of
the growth mindset classroom culture
that fosters and empowers the students
to use their growth mindsets
and one follow-up question before i i'm
i think what vicky's work is very
complementary to everything you just
talked about but i'm curious carol and
i've never asked you this
what got you into this research what was
the reason that you you kind of started
formulating this whole
theory around growth mindset and testing
it
if i can start in childhood but i'm not
gonna go
every year
um
and if you ask me who's my most
influential teacher it's mrs wilson my
sixth grade teacher who seated us around
the room in iq order
wow
i thought
even as
a sixth grader i thought
this is so wrong
i know the kids in this class i've been
with them for years you can't sort them
point by point into iq
nonetheless i was sucked into her system
i wanted to succeed within her framework
so years later
when i
fell in love with psychology
and saw that you could use science to
study people's beliefs motivations
i
i thought i'm going to study
why some children are able to fulfill
their potential
by taking on challenges and sticking to
them and other kids who may be
really really skilled
never
achieve what they're capable of and in
graduate school i embarked on the line
of research that i'm still pursuing
it's fascinating i definitely want to
come back to that but
you know vicki tell us about escuela
nueva what what was the reason you
started it and what is the core
underlying principle of of of what's
made it what it is
escuela nueva a citizen a word in
spanish
new school
well first of all it's not so new
anymore it's one of the longest
bottom-up
innovations in the developing world
that's still being sustained it's like a
pedagogical movement
nothing new in the philosophy of
education
all the things we know that the great
pedagogue said at the beginning of
century
good child-centered learning not
everybody learns the same thing at the
same time self-paced learning children
learn looking into their eyes dialoguing
and constructing knowledge together
so it's cooperative learning a new role
of the teacher as a great mentor a
facilitator that has more time to really
focus on the human dimension
so we we started thinking about all
these things by necessity because
we started with the isolated
rural
multi-grade schools invisible schools of
developing countries and of course in
colombia where we started
and
basically we wanted to introduce these
concepts of of good pedagogy all these
ideas exist that have existed for so
many years with john dewey what maria
montessori
you know all of these but these ideas
came only to the elite schools in latin
america not to the poorest to the poor
so i'm originally a sociologist and but
of course i had a wonderful
mother she was a great teacher that did
a lot in colombia and founded teachers
colleges and she was always talking
about child-centered learning
and so i had a contrast because of what
i received in good quality schools
private schools and what i was seeing in
reality with the most isolated rural
children of colombia so i wanted to
introduce the concept of equity
reduce inequity i wanted to introduce
the concept of really child centered
learning to improve quality in in
education
um
21st century skills
and and of course the new role of the
teacher so uh this these rural schools
there were so many difficulties that we
really had to have a paradigm shift
from transmission of knowledge
to social construction of knowledge
and we really wanted
to incorporate and and strengthen the
relationship between citizenship
building and your pedagogy
so i guess these ideas and and the
necessity for us necessity was the
mother of innovation
uh so i say it's a little bit like we
had to learn how to transform all this
complexity into simple manageable action
so that anybody any teacher without
having a phd could have results so i
think these are the little tricks we
have in escuela nueva which means new
school and as i said is one of the
longest ones innovations of the
developing world that's still being
sustained and that has inspired of
course many uh innovations worldwide
like the vietnamese for example
from colombia to vietnam
and now there's tens of thousands of of
these schools i mean it is at scale for
for anyone who hasn't seen a a new
school in escuela nueva
what would it look like like it sounds
very different than that teacher that
carol had lined up
what does it look like what would you
hear and see
totally when you go when you when you go
into an escuela school you see
um it's an example of democracy in a way
by the way we're going through all these
crisis and processes
but but
you see some children working in some
things by themselves in pairs
others working in small groups
some are going to their learning corners
it's a learning environment that has
changed they're permanently talking and
dialoguing and you see a teacher walking
around when children call on the teacher
not the other way around when the
children call on the teacher because we
really wanted to be child-centered
you see the teacher
going through the different groups
talking individually with some talking
in pairs with others you see some
children going out of the classroom to
do an experiment by themselves
they're working with their learning
guides they have their a lot of
self-governing instruments to promote
school government and democracy
and we really want to incorporate a
culture of participation so there are
many little tricks uh that we see that
strengthen self-esteem
discovery learning child-centered their
their self-concept you know we want them
to really enjoy learning
and and i think we have seen this in
these very isolated rural schools of
colombia and of other countries where we
have worked with
and how did you feel
i mean i think that's the most important
thing on a lot of levels
how did this happen i mean i could
imagine especially if you're going to
rural areas
the teacher's notion of what a teacher
does is very true probably very
traditional someone at a chalkboard
lecturing while t students have fingers
on lips and listening
how were you able to manage the
controlled chaos so to speak of multiple
students working at their own time and
pace and you did this even before edtech
became a real tool
explain the logistics of it and then i
actually want to connect it because it
sounds very complementary to everything
that carol was mentioning
totally totally that's why we say with
carol we fell in love with each other
because carol coming from such solid
scientific research and me coming from
such necessity
and and and and
and complexity um
there are let's say
the question you ask me is how do they
know what they're doing and how they are
well we had to develop first of all
we had to change the teachers attitudes
we wanted to make sure that teachers
be trained with the same methodology
they will be using with their students
because we're asking teachers to make
the change
and they've been exposed to very
traditional teacher-centered learning
when they were in when they were
students where they were studying so the
first thing we had to do was you know
try to
change what most faculties of education
and teachers colleges are not doing
so we wanted that teachers
go through the same process they will be
doing with their children second we
would like them to see a demo school
just so that they would say we can do it
it's nothing complicated we can
perfectly do this and the third thing
was not leave the teachers alone we had
to create a community of practice so
because teachers learn more from each
other than from experts
and of course the whole idea was
introduced the concept of flexibility
you know
act
time and space we have to introduce a
whole concept of flexibility in these
terms
and because
learning is not a place it's an activity
okay so
we have learned that many of the most
important activities take place in their
homes with their parents
and
and so we just wanted to make sure that
all these ideas were incorporated in
what we were doing and we were really
transforming all this complexity into
simple
manageable action we had to make it
simple simple
replicable
scalable
and cost effective
no super powerful
i'm already getting a ton of questions
from uh social media so i want to make
sure i get to as many of these as
possible and these are connected to the
work that both of y'all are doing
from youtube joshua cadavel asks it's
very difficult to motivate ourselves
into a growth mindset what do you
suggest to help us get into that mindset
i'll start with carol who's who knows
the science and the research here but
then after that i'd also love to learn
from vicki because if all of your
students have this agency and it's real
student-centered learning i'm assuming a
lot of them need the same growth mindset
as well but but carol what advice do you
have for josh or anyone listening on how
do you get into that mindset
how old is josh
i have no idea he's on youtube
okay
whether you're a student or an adult
you have to ask yourself
what
do you want to do what do you care about
what do you want to contribute to the
world in your life
and then
how do i get there
you'll need to take on challenges you'll
need to know
that
everybody struggles through challenges
everybody has setbacks it's part of
learning
your
fixed mindset voice will come back to
you a lot and say this is too hard you
were unrealistic you can't do that and
you have to talk back to it not go away
i don't like you you're in my way
but hey
i want to try this can you come on board
and collaborate with me
can you
um
contribute with me can you let me try
this so
where we all have both mindsets the
fixed mindset is ready to trap back in
and
discourage you
when things are hard or you have a
failure but you have to
get it on
board
get it on your side and keep in mind
what you're trying to accomplish and who
you're doing it for
and and vicki i'll actually add this
extra question uh from youtube and it
actually turns out josh is 16 so i
guessed correctly somehow i'm i'm clear
rolling in somewhere
but from youtube there's a related
question julian miller asks uh mrs dweck
and and vicki how would you get about go
about getting a younger student with low
self-esteem to gain a growth mindset and
vicky i love your take first because
you've very i'm assuming you've
essentially had to do this i don't know
when you started
escuela nueva whether you thought that
you were doing growth mindset but now
there's the science from carol behind it
but but how have you thought about
motivating kids reinforcing a growth
mindset versus a fixed mindset
yes i think the first thing we wanted to
make sure is that children
love school you know that they that they
would have a nice environment despite
that it's a rural isolated school
um
you know that would be a nice pleasant
environment so i think that that's
crucial
the second thing was you know that they
would feel the love from their teacher
not classifying them but a teacher that
would always you know open the doors to
them and give them the love and
affection they're needing because
they're really needing so much affection
and love and a nice warm place and
environment where they can they can be
safe
a wonderful aspect was you know to
motivate children to intrinsic
motivation i'm not a psychologist i
don't know much about it but we wanted
children to have a little bit of
self-concept to know that they could be
happy learning
and we developed all these very simple
instruments of to promote autonomy to
promote self-determination
uh
the the the flexibility that you know
all children can learn if you give them
the time and that they don't have to
compete with anybody else but that they
can go on their own rhythm
and uh and you know the motivation the
self-regulation there are many many
instruments of self-governing
instruments where children control their
own attendance you know where they have
all these simple instruments of the
school governments where where children
elect and
are elected and they have their school
government with their projects concrete
projects they have with their parents in
their community so we had to think of
all these little tricks to make sure
that any teacher
could have a wonderful classroom and a
nice environment that all children could
learn if you give them if you give them
the time and a nice safe environment so
it's a really a whole concept of child
friendly concept
that we wanted to embrace so the school
was a place where children want didn't
want to leave
they wanted to stay
because they had a loving teacher and
they had their their classmates where
they worked together and they learned to
dialogue and so i mean they're very
simple tricks that we had to incorporate
but they've demonstrated that it can be
done yes we can introduce quality
reduce inequity
incorporate leadership skills from the
beginning it's amazing to see these
little children you know
taking responsibilities and assuming
their responsibilities
and leading others and learning to work
in teams i have to say i had a professor
at stanford elizabeth cohen um that i
she you know for the first time i
learned about cooperative learning you
know here in latin america we talk about
personalized learning but not
cooperative learning and we have seen
the results because let's say we've
always have tried to have some empirical
research behind so for example the
university of london published one of
our first research
papers and demonstrating the impact of
escuela on peaceful social interaction
of children not only on academic
achievement but on peaceful behavior and
i think this is so important coming out
of columbia very important
no thanks for that vicky and and carol
you know same question there's a younger
you say there's a younger student that
you
how how does a parent or a teacher or
anyone who cares about them
try to bring you know the question was
specifically if they have a low
self-esteem to have a growth mindset
we've all met kids or sometimes we've
been that kid where we're like oh i'm
not good at
this my brain isn't wired for that
what do you tell them what do you do
well first i want to say one of the
hundreds or even thousand things i love
about
vicky's work and her schools is that she
takes a fixed mindset off the table
it doesn't occur to students in that
environment
to worry about being measured
but in our culture it's really different
parents worry
about how smart their children are
parents measure them then they go to
school they're tested
they're compared to each other
teachers often decide
who's the smart and who's not as smart
so
it's not
a surprise that we have a lot of young
students with low self-esteem now
my research and the research
of others like eddie brahman and the
netherlands shows that sometimes people
react to kids with low self-esteem
by telling them how smart they are by or
by over praising them
which actually makes them more
vulnerable to failure in the future
i would say
the research suggests
keep the focus on learning
keep the focus on progress keep the
focus on challenging yourself
say to a child who
did something easily oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry i wasted your time that was
too easy for you you must have been
bored let's do something fun something
you can learn from
if the child gets stuck and discouraged
on something
be
that backup support like vicky's
teachers
what can you let's see what you've done
what can you think of doing next let's
let's try that
so this detective process of
what
you didn't understand and how you can
understand it
makes that whole process fun
we've seen that parents who believe that
failure can inspire their child's
learning
are much better mentors to their kids
than parents who worry
that their child's failures will harm
them and make them feel
incompetent so this whole
focus on challenge progress
learning from setbacks
is what goes into this natural love of
learning as opposed to the self-doubt
that comes from feeling
measured and compared
yeah and there's a lot of questions
coming in i mean i think everyone this
resonates with anyone listening anyone
who's who
at any level of depth on this and i
think a lot of the questions are the
flavor of you know how do we actually
put this out there in the world we you
know we talked about how you can do it
as an individual or how you could even
change your own mindset we know we have
this question i'm paraphrasing from
youtube jamal shaheed how would this
look in an urban school
from youtube manish raj jaiswal
um they're talking about
stereotypical south asian parents uh
that are more grades oriented versus
skill oriented how do you change that so
that the broader broader question is
how do you scale this because both of
you all have scaled this idea in
different ways um carol what are you
where do you think we are where do
versus where do you think we can be and
i'll ask you
where we are versus where we could be
i'll tell you exactly where we are
we have shown that
direct to student growth mindset
programs
can work um they can raise the
achievement the grades of lower
achievers they can inspire even higher
achievers to take
more advanced math courses
but
if a student has taken this program and
goes back into say a math classroom with
a teacher who's created a fixed mindset
culture they can't put that into
practice they can't thrive there
in the special way that their growth
mindset might have allowed them to
so then we realized
we have to
create a program for teachers
um just the way vicky has
created a scalable program
we
realized david yeager mary murphy and i
we realized
we've got to have
modules
that can scale up that we can
disseminate widely
that will
prevent teachers from
trying to implement it in ways that
don't work
we're in the middle of that now
vicki is a valued valued consultant in
this project
this fall
we're going to
test
administer and test the the first
version of this
we'll we'll do this the next year as
well when it's tested and ready it will
be available at no cost to all teachers
uh we're doing it on an adolescent
population
it's the hardest thing we've ever done
it's the most important thing
we've ever done and we're working on it
around the clock
no thank thanks for that carol and vicki
i mean you're already at the scale i
mean tell me what scale you're at i i've
read tens of thousands of schools i
don't know how many students that is but
i'm guessing hundreds of thousands or
millions of students across countries so
you're already at a lot of scale
but
how far do you think you're on this
journey where do you think we could be
in five or ten years what's your hope
my hope is that we can continue to move
forward however there are many lessons
learned from this process uh
of how to work with whom do you work
well
going back to your initial question to
to uh carol
we we have sort of had to also
modularize the curriculum curriculums
are you know like they're like big
beasts how do you tackle the national
curriculum
so the first thing is we had to break it
up in chunks modularize it to facilitate
flexibility because we wanted to
incorporate the concept of self-paced
learning and flexibility
so it's an important aspect of the
escuela nueva so the students ability to
progress through their learning
materials their learning guides using
both self-assessments and group
assessments
and but we believe that this flexibility
has helped a lot because in this way
students know that they can achieve even
even even if you're going a little bit
slower so it's the whole concept of
flexibility that we had to introduce
uh in in the curriculum and the way we
work with the children in everything so
this was for us really really crucial
and of course we we also i mean when we
scaled up we learned to work with
governments which is something that i
have also learned you have to work with
governments
because we learned how to make it a
national policy
but you need governments
for big impact and coverage
but you need the role of civil society
and public-private partnerships for two
key words quality and sustainability
there are many countries where we have
started escuela nueva in brazil in
guatemala and all these places in latin
america beyond we've inspired in in
zambia
but the thing is that you know one of
the big issues is that we we have
inspired many countries but
you get that the project started it
starts moving on and then governments
change so this is another lesson learned
from all this process not only the let's
say the curriculum dimensions of how to
modularize curious and make them
flexible to adapt that the school adapts
to the children and not the other way
around because by the way i have to
highlight the initial way when we had to
make it flexible because children in
rural areas have to walk long distances
because children participate in picking
crops with their parents so it's a
mobile
population
by the way we have adapted escuela nueva
to urban contexts collective urbana
and especially for migrant and displaced
populations right now we're working with
many many venezuelan migrants in
colombia and it's been a successful
program where we adapt this is in the
cities of colombia not in the rural
areas so this is where we adapt to the
needs of the child and not the other way
around that the school really is open
and flexible and this is what we really
have tried to do and to maintain this
flexibility i don't know if i answered
your question correctly but i i picked
up on other things
no that was incredibly valuable and you
know
this conversation i thought we were like
five minutes into it because i'm so
intrigued and i realized that we're
pretty much uh pretty pretty much at
time and i i apologize to everyone
there's so many good questions that have
been coming in on social media but uh
you know i i'll leave it up to y'all uh
maybe a last word from either of you on
you know messages you have for folks who
are both fascinated by these models
fascinated by growth mindset but also
fascinated by y'all as individuals and
are looking to have similar impact in
their life uh you know what what
messages would you have for them maybe
maybe carol's start and then followed by
vicky
that's a big one
first i just want to underscore
something vicki said how important
equity is an education
how important it is for schools to adopt
to the culture
adapt to the culture and needs
of students
some growth mindset
a growth mindset assessment into a
a recent survey and testing
and found that growth mindset
not only predicted achievement
in much or most of the world of the 79
countries and economies but also
motivation to learn
well-being
it gave a bigger boost
to vulnerable students low-income
immigrants it narrowed the gap
between the rich and poor the immigrants
and non-immigrants so
we're
caring about kids lives their well-being
and again
we want to inspire them to think about
the contributions they want to make i'm
worried kids aren't going to want to
come back to school after the pandemic
they're going to feel behind
let's get them inspired by a
contribution that they hope to make
let's get them ready to do it let's keep
them in school
let's make schools they want to be in
in order to learn how to make their
contribution
and i think
um
just one more thing i think the pandemic
has taught so many teachers how much
caring about the students matters being
part of their
lives matters
how much being
integrated integrating the school with
the community matters
and
not just the teaching and testing
but creating a culture that makes
students love learning and
learn optimally
thanks it's so inspiring vicky
i guess reinforcing what carol says is i
want to say it can be done
yes it can be done in the most
isolated and the most impoverished areas
of many of our countries it can be done
we demonstrated that with the unesco
study the first comparative
international study of unesco in latin
america years back i think it was in the
year 2000 um
colombia and cuba were the only two
countries where rural schools
outperformed urban schools
except in the mega cities demonstrated
that yes you can reduce inequity it's
possible
but also
um
not not only that but
it compensates for socio-economic
inequalities this is what we wanted to
demonstrate that it can be done
but also the children learn and the
children love learning and they continue
but because more of the same is not
enough
i think this is important we really have
to make this change in education and i
i'm quoting someone like that i heard
and i always say mention it because
people not understand
you know if we bring a
doctor from a hundred years back into a
hospital today that doctor is lost
because everything has changed
permanently so much
but if we bring a teacher from 100 years
ago
and to a classroom today even in an
elite school that teacher is not so lost
because everything has changed except
the way of learning
so this is why this is the powerful
message it can be done but more of the
same is not enough we have to make these
changes
no well thank you both for for spending
the time with us honestly for your
decades of incredible work which i think
is just getting started
on the impact on humanity
i want to a special thanks to the don
prize foundation which has a mission of
creating a better world through
education uh supports practices and
education for
putting us all together uh we're all on
this uh what they call council of
luminaries which we're proud to serve on
but uh you know i i both i i look to
both of your work for inspiration all
the time and we're thinking through khan
academy as you know
you know i was more in listening mode
today but everything that we stand for
is essentially what you all stand for
how do we give students agency how do we
ensure that teachers have the
information so that they can do more
focused work with students more human
work with students students can learn at
their own time and pace you need a
measure you need to assess but it
shouldn't be a statement on who you are
it should just be a statement on where
you where where you're at and so this
even this notion of mastery learning and
if you're at an eighty percent not a big
deal keep working on it get to a ninety
percent get to get to 100 which which it
feels very closely aligned with this
notion of of of everything you'll do so
thank you so much for being part of this
wonderful to be with you sal wonderful
to have met you a bit in person thank
you and hope to meet you someday in
person
great to see you again sal nice to see
you also
well well thanks everyone for for
joining as you can tell we could have
spoken to for several hours to each of
carol and vicki they really are titans
in the field of education it actually
turns out that a couple of uh years ago
i was at a restaurant and i and i saw
them uh having i i i'm pretty sure it
was carol and it might have been vicky
as well
and and i was just like oh they they
won't want to talk to me but just right
before this i said hey you know i saw
you at the restaurant like why didn't
you come by i was like i didn't want to
bother y'all uh but but anyway there
there are two heroes of mine uh they've
done profound work that's already
impacted the world and i think is going
to only impact the world more and more
over the decorate decades and
generations to come and as i mentioned
uh everything we do here at khan academy
is about trying to empower exactly what
they're up to
you know in order for someone have a
growth mindset about learning they
should be able to learn at their own
time and pace if they haven't mastered
it keep working on it that the role of
the classroom
should not be
one
way flow of information lecture everyone
sitting passively silent it should be
everyone working together students
working with each other the teacher
walking around forming human connections
we should create ability for students to
have agency uh over their own learning
which might be actually the most
important skill of all even more
important than any of the academic
skills uh so thank you for joining uh
and hopefully you enjoyed that
conversation
you